I and I do you recommend taking loo balls orally or topically. What if you do not
have cancer diagnosis? What about the caplets? First of all, I'm not a real big band of
loo balls brand. It's just, I like the iodine that is more kelp-based.
I and I now most iodide does have potassium iodide in it as well, most iodide supplements.
But some have some kelp-based nutrients in it as well. That being said, should you
take it orally or topically? You will absorb some liquid iodine
so you can do iodine topically. If you have breast cancer, you can put topical
iodide right over your over the tumor site close to the tumor site.
There can be benefit to that. But oral iodide is beneficial as well.
We have our, I think it's called, clear, selenium plus iodide product.
That's the one I recommend to most people. Biotic research has a liquid iodide.
I think it's called iodide forte, liquid iodide forte. I think what it's called.
That's a good product too. But the clear, selenium plus iodide is my favorite one.
That's a capsule. What's the benefit of iodine?
So the benefit of iodine is you need iodine to make tea tree and tea for in your thyroid.
Iodine also can be beneficial with horrible driven cancers.
So breast cancer can be a factor and need for iodine. Also, iodine can be protective of your thyroid
in the case of your take the radiation or your exposed to radiation.
That would be another reason to take iodine. So those would be the reasons to take iodine.
But we've got to remember iodine is, that's a mineral, but you can overtake.
You can take too much of it. So I would just use what's, what is suggested on the bottom of this is a safe dosage.